good morning everyone i'm chris mcdonald
i'm the vice president of data science
engineering and operations at chroma
code we're a molecular diagnostics
company i'll talk a little bit about
what we do as we go through it but i'm
here to talk to you today about our
approach using data science for product
development field monitoring and
understanding how our products are
performing
normally when you think of traditional
qpcr you think of a signal that looks
something like this you have a signal
that amplifies across a couple of cycles
you have this amplification and then it
levels out at some point using this you
detect whether the signal passes some
threshold and a threat threshold is
passed you would call that target
detected this allows you to put one
target in each color channel of a qpcr
machine so in the case of this cartoon
over here of this four channel
instrument you get up to four targets
that are detected
for chromocodes technology what we do is
we also encode using the amplitude of
the intensity of the targets so if you
can imagine a traditional target one
here that when it's present in a qpcr
reaction amplifies it to 50 fluorescence
intensity units
and then at target 2 that when it's
present in a reaction amplifies to 100
intensity units in the same channel in
channel 1 then if it's at this 50 i
could tell that it's target 1. if i read
100 it's target 2. and if i read 150 i
know that targets 1 and 2 are present
by arranging the targets the intensities
the concentration of the molecular
components at different amounts so that
we get a unique intensity for every
target and every combination of targets
lets us resolve
three or four targets per channel in a
qpcr reaction this enables on the order
of 10 to 20 targets in qpcr and up to 50
targets in digital pcr the way that this
is all mapped out we call the code space
and so when we have a target level one
two and four these black ones our
targets one two and three map there we
call that the code space
as i mentioned what this allows us to do
is out of four channel instruments an
example getting up to 16 targets per
channel and then on a digital pcr
instrument we have a higher amount that
we can encode getting up to 50 targets
per channel
and this allows us to create a lot of
panels that we're talking about but also
this means that we have a huge burden in
development to create these highly
multiplex assays and so what we're going
to talk about throughout this after we
get through the introduction is some of
the ways that we leverage data science
tools in order to enable this technology
key components of our asset
is that we are a digital pcr and digital
pcr assay development company we sell
the reagents we also utilize an
interlock data cloud for analyzing the
data so you upload your data to the
cloud you get back a report that tells
you what targets are present in that
sample this keeps cost lows for the labs
this is also instrument agnostic so
whichever pcr instrument you have on
hand is the pcr instrument that you can
use for this asset
key features with this then we have the
reagent kits that enable the 4x
capability on the qpcr installed base
but then using the software informatics
cloud you get data analysis and
reporting for the customers a scalable
network effect as well as knowledge the
feeds back to us to help us improve the
tests improve the customer experience to
be able to deliver more to those
customers
what that ends up looking like here is
that when you have a cloud you upload
the run to the qpcr run file to the
cloud the automatic analysis or the
results on that cloud infrastructure and
then the visualization gets delivered
back to the customer and the results are
reported at this point we have a
database of over 5 million tests with
over 825 million data entries that we've
done primarily from our covid testing
assay
uh of the five million tests probably
the majority of them are from that two
big uses that we have on the data
science side that we
use for this really is number one
helping develop real-time lab or
customer data so being able to collect
and manage this highly multiplex
diagnostic data to provide either
epidemiological insights understanding
and helping customers understand their
inventory their workflow their
efficiency and helping customers support
being able to zoom in very quickly
online and resolve any issues that are
happening with customers has been
incredibly valuable for us as we built
out this cloud infrastructure
in addition uh anonymized aggregated
data is something that allows us to take
a look at these chemical signatures from
the qpcr and do things like supply chain
monitoring we always want to ensure that
we have the best possible production and
performance
for our different
targets and our different assays in
there so monitoring supply chain quality
using this to improve our assays also
for public health implications as an
example we all know that strain variants
happen from time to time in coronavirus
being able to stay on top of that
ensuring that none of the
strain variants are impacting our assay
or if they do
being able to detect that and improve
our assay and also know that there is a
local strain variant that's potentially
impacting the the assay can be of huge
importance we haven't seen one yet but
we're on the lookout out for it on a
daily basis
as far as the different applications
that we do and that we're really
interested in in applying all of these
tools for is really understanding a lot
of the applications around where you use
ngs ngs currently is really great for
biomarker discovery we'll talk a little
bit about oncology coming up a little
bit later
their instruments tend to be expensive
the workflows can be complex and slow
and there's a lot of data that you have
to work through to compute your answers
on the contrast with qpcr it's simple
there's cheaper instruments it's faster
and it's very easy to compute the data
if you think about qpcr it's often a
single portion of the workflow of ngs
you know you might have an amplicon
sequencing product where you're looking
at a specific set of markers so nds is
great for discovery but when you know
what you're looking for and you can
reduce the amount of things that you're
looking for pcr can be a valuable
tool in someone's arsenal to be able to
understand what targets are present in
the sample or what to do about something
that's happening
the idea here is that if you look on two
axes you have one axis which is the
speed to result or the cost efficiency
of being able to get to an answer about
some particular sample and then also the
amount of content that you get there's a
cost and content gap where the amount of
high content results for the speech
result is very important provides an
avenue for us to go in and inhabit and
then try and provide the answers that
can only be done with ngs
in general data science approaches to
being able to do this and compress
information into different results is
not new in the life sciences
there's been quite a few different
companies that are involved in various
different areas in life sciences so from
pcr ai and eugen tech automating pcr
analysis improving accuracy using
artificial intelligence and digital
pathology whether it's ibex path ai page
or crochet as well as machine learning
for single cell analysis bd epic is
doing a lot of work down here in san
diego as well on that side as well as
clever culture systems and innumerable
companies are exploring this
one of the interesting things i learned
when i got into the biotech area is that
although it's a very different subject
matter
you know the models really are the same
when you look at the applications of
data science so if you might be in the
tech industry and you're doing image
analysis algorithms to try and classify
images you might have a problem to look
something like this you know you have
this picture here you're trying to
determine whether this this
picture here contains a cat or a dog so
what you do is you take this image you
train it on some either deep neural
network or other model which has an
input layer some neurons and an output
layer and then you go through that
decision process and then the final
output of this is that you see a dog
present the data science workflow for
image classification for serving
advertisements for analyzing cells
to determine whether there's
pathological cells in the sample to
analyze mgs data to determine what base
pairs are present what mutations are
present really fundamentally are the
same
so while the neural network might be
trained on something different the whole
process around going through the data
science steps to understand what is done
is the same
the core data science workflow that
anybody is going to to undergo typically
has four major phases or all divided up
the initial phase really where you want
to decide on the problem you're trying
to answer and acquire some data about
that problem whether it's in a different
cat whether it's a slide or a histology
slide that has some cells that you're
trying to classify
the same idea you start with and then
you put down into your pipeline
the next step is called pre-processing
this is where you clean the data so you
may have data that is is useless maybe
some of the slides are broken maybe some
of the images aren't really usable
then the next step you do is you extract
features so in the case of a facial
recognition the features you might
extract are things like the distance
between the eyes the size of the nose
the size of the mouth the different
features around the face and then you
can use that to compare one image to
another in the case of a cell you're
looking at the number of cells the size
of the cells the shape color if they're
stained and things like that or in the
case of qpcr we're looking at the
features of of the different curves
from that point once you've extracted
features you go through a process called
feature engineering this is taking a
look at those features and trying to
figure out what's important about the
classification that you are trying to do
so again in the case of facial
recognition maybe the the distance
between eyes is a is a very important
feature that lets me recognize uh case
one to phase two to say three but
whether
you know the the shade of the skin isn't
as much
a differentiator because
many people look similar
in that respect
after that you're gonna have some
missing data some pictures are
incomplete some faces are done at
different angles some cells are missing
from different ones once you figure all
that out you're done with the
pre-processing step
at that point you generate a model so
that the models you do then try and make
some prediction about what i see so
under these certain parameters under
these certain circumstances i think that
this is going to be a cat where this is
going to be a dog or this cell comes
from a tumor sample or a normal sample
or it's pathological or it's not
pathological
you try this in many ways you might do a
neural network model you might do some
more simple linear models to make a
decision on these parameters and then
you evaluate and you select which model
is giving you those best predictions
after that during that modeling process
you evaluate the performance you go get
more pictures of cats or dogs or cells
or whatever you need to take a look at
and then you see does it predict
accurately on this new data what i'm
trying to do and if the answer is yes
then you can then take that model and
put it into production to go get answers
again in the case of image
classification your google search or
your facebook image tagging and in the
case of cells trying to predict for a
new sample whether that contains some
pathological cells whether they're you
know tumor cells or or something of the
like and in our case uh whether the pcr
signals have target one two or three
that are are present in a particular
sample and how you deal with other
features of the the data set like the
wells of the pcr plate or the the
non-uniformity of lenses or other things
that we need to correct for in order to
make sure that we get the right right
data every time
sometimes you're going to go through
this process you're going to value the
performance and it's not going to be so
good so maybe you get down here and you
predicted the picture if it's a cat and
it's actually not a cat and so
what happens then well in the case of
big data or machine learning or image
classification the the typical way that
you will go through it is to go and get
more data and so this is a pretty
difficult approach this is what you'll
see in google or something like that if
you have hundreds of thousands of images
to classify from there's a huge and rich
data source to get that data from so you
take that data and then you go back and
then you're able to uh provide more uh
more data and then go back through your
evaluation to performance and then get
through all those different pieces
so this is critical and this is really
important when you're trying to evaluate
your model you go back through it and
you get better answers this is also an
example of how you might work for
analysis of the self-driving car data
these google cars tesla cars are out
here collecting more and more data as
time goes refining their algorithms and
getting better and better and better
the key thing here though to understand
is what this means that in big data the
company that has the most data is the
one with the edge an example here is
grail which has done a fantastic job
looking at many many samples and trying
to understand you know how do i detect
cancer early using just the dna that's
in the blood and looking at markers that
are in there this is a huge fundraising
process to get in there and get tons of
samples and look at a lot of data with
just incredible results that they've had
and and really great outcomes for the
company
this is great and for companies that
that are able to do that this is really
powerful that's not necessarily true of
all companies one of them being ours
where we can't necessarily go and get
more data than anybody else
that is out there
so what do you do so if you if you go
and you come up with the wrong one but
instead of being able to get more data
another approach that you could
potentially have that might
differentiate this
is maybe you can go out and generate
your own data so when i when i spoke of
feature engineering before in the
classic sense of the the data science
loop
what that really means is determining
what features are available that already
exist in that data for example the the
eye width is predictive of uh the you
know
face facial recognition algorithm or for
cats versus dogs maybe it's the ear
shape as an example well in the case of
for us when we design qpcr assays and in
the case for a lot of biotech companies
they're actually creating the chemistry
that creates those features we design
taqman primers and probes we designed
the chemistry we designed the dyes we
designed the image algorithms and so in
the sense that what we can do is we can
use feature engineering which actually
means a biochemist tweaking some assay
or trying to decide distance to be
brighter to be dimmer do i need to
switch the dyes out
and and so we call that literally also
feature engineering and in akin to
facial recognition algorithms if i could
re-engineer cats so that they always had
a green hat on top of them then it would
be very easy for me to distinguish a cat
and a dog all i have to do is look for
the giant green hat that i don't have to
worry about whether the facial distance
i shave or the nose or anything like
that it's predictive always of every
breed of cat or dogs because i have a
very obvious and a clear feature in
which to train my data on
so qpcr provides the right field for
being able to do this if you've designed
an assay before you have control over
the die but not only the die but all the
components within the reaction you know
you have your dna sample that comes in
you have primers probes nucleotides your
attack polymerase or other components on
the enzymes you have your buffer your
small molecules your salt the type of
tube you make this thermal cycler
cycling conditions you have this huge
parameter space with which to operate
and typically with asset development
in order to get the pcr signal now in
the case of
really the data scientists getting them
in the loop early so that you can take a
look at those data and try to understand
well hey you know if you could do this
thing a little bit brighter or dimmer if
you could do this or you could do that
that increases the resolvability on the
end of what you're trying to do
then you're gonna really be able to
drive to to a solution that is much
uh
much more distinguished between the
different results that you might try and
do
and so in in the case here right so if
you think about the pcr we started with
a simple pcr curve reaction initiates
amplification reaction terminates here
you get one piece of data out in the
case of let's say a a sorry 122 assay
that we have currently on the market or
any essay that you might be developing
right so what you're getting is you
measure 60 floating point measurements i
get 60 cycles worth of data or 40 cycles
or 20 cycles or however many you're
doing and you get a number that's down
to you know five decimal points of the
different amount of fluorescence
intensity that you get and you reduce
all of that data down to one thing
whether stars cove two is present in in
the data world or in information theory
world you call that one bit of
information theory entropy where either
my target is present or my target is not
present what that also means is you're
throwing away most of that data so as
you go and you start engineering the
qpcr curve to be able to generate
different features
for different amplifications you might
have one target that amplifies very
early at a very high concentration and
then a second target in the same channel
amplify later in a second amplification
what that looks like is two pcr curves
stacked on top of each other on the left
and maybe those are totally operate
totally independent from each other and
the
the data works great and then your app
is going to work out of the box but
sometimes they're correlated with each
other so using the data science tools in
order to be able to determine why are
they correlating under what situation
and feeding that back onto the
biochemistry team allows you to just
dictate things you know using the
enzymes of salts really all these
different components dictate the curve
shape such that then your features can
then become independent of each other
circling back to the initial
slide that we started with that's really
how you build up to assets in our case
you know what we're interested in is
compressing information into qpcr
signals so you can get 16 targets in a
four channel a few pcr system 50 targets
and a five channel digital pcr system as
an example
so we're interested in utilizing those
tools in order to compress more
information into the same qpcr signal
in other cases you know epic sciences or
other image recognition algorithms
you're talking about looking at
different stains or different images to
try and extract features you also can do
this exact same loop where you're trying
to extract these features from it but
you also have the ability to perturb
that system whether it's through
choosing you know dies and pacman
primers and probes in our case of qpcr
or in the case of some cell slide
looking at how you stain them looking at
what kind of
what you attach to it what markers and
things that you do there
what does this result in well here as an
example we do have several infectious
disease assays on the market but another
way that you can look at it right is is
uh here we have a proof of principles
just three markers in uh and that's the
non-small cell lung carcinoma assay uh
that is under development uh to be able
to look at multiple markers within a
single well so in this case this is
looking at three markers in a single
channel on a qpcr instrument
building that out allows us to generate
the sensitivity with with qpcr and qpcr
you have you know down to one percent
minor allele fraction but then in
digital pcr you can get even
significantly lower than that as well
for things applications like liquid
biopsy
then developing that and expanding that
allows you to generate full coverage
across the you know 15 to 20 markers
that you might need for a full uh
non-smell small cell lung carcinoma
panel just using qpcr digital pcr the
value here with for us an interesting
you know side is that you know using the
techniques of information compression
you know you're able to generate a full
coverage and with the time the result of
hours without needing a central lab for
a very low cost of sample
and this all goes back to that
observation that when you're looking at
a sample and you don't know what you're
looking for of course you're going to
need to sequence you're going to need to
look at a huge depth of information to
try and decide what do i do about the
sampling what do i do going on in the
future
when you know what you're looking for
and the subset of markers is really only
10 to 20 to be able to guide the
decision or be able to understand what
you're looking for in a sample
then you can start to do that in the
qpcr digital pcr space and start to
generate a lot of value because what
we're here for is really to improve that
for you know our customers but also
ultimately for the patients that want to
use this technology
so taking that and taking that running
that all the way to the ground all the
way at the end you know you're trying to
look at several different things and
this is where the development gets a lot
more complicated and those tools that we
talk about get even more important
you're trying to get signals to get
generated whether it's a signal
nucleotide variant deletions insertions
fusions coming on and these different
things that you're looking for you know
sometimes there's eight different rat
fusions that might happen you know eight
different drops one uh some of the you
know egfr exon 20 mutation insertions
there's multiple that you see as well uh
exon skipping deletions as well so
there's a lot of information that come
out of this and so utilizing those tools
is critical otherwise you wouldn't be
able to do this development
so the key here is really integrating
the the data science team into that
development as opposed to just just
having it at the end of the cycle we're
using it to try and understand product
performance or performance in the field
and we'll get to that as well in just a
moment
but to summarize this part of the
of the talk i think the the key here is
to
to really put that together taking
control of that data structuring allows
new applications on existing tools in
our case our interest is digital ccr and
qpcr and we think of
you know chemistry as the opportunity to
structure that data so the data
structuring activity the qpcr instrument
converts that data into some digital
signal that has an output and those
outputs we engineer to be distinct
depending on what targets are present
and then we're able to do the science
and the analysis in the cloud to do
things you know enabling respiratory
virus markup marker panels antibiotic
marker research uh information on
chromosomal anemoploidies for
you know not uh prenatal samples and
delivery of oncology uh mutations or
information on this that are present in
the sample very very quickly
this all doesn't happen in a vacuum you
know we talked about the cloud over here
and so it's also key and important to
build up the infrastructure that is
allows us to do the analysis both on our
internal samples but also be able to
support this in production as we go to
uh to customers and so while there's a
range of qpr instruments they'll go and
then they'll upload upload the data we
get the analysis and we export the test
results back it's really key that we
develop this in a in a manner that is
not only
effective for us but also secure and
private for our our customers so you
need to develop this out in our case the
chromocode cloud is a fully hipaa
compliant solution that does the
instrument characterization analysis uh
visualization reporting and has secure
and scalable data management we do this
through architecting the cloud and
dividing up the part where we do the
data management the actual analysis the
visualization reporting in aws in a
hipaa compliance environment and then
the the data uploaded and then the test
reports for the customers come in and
out of it but we're able to lock that
down and keep that secure
this allows us to do several things
number one is allow us to see what's
going on in the field so for us we're
not so interested in what our customers
doing that's their job we want them to
be able to access data to help
themselves but we do want to know things
like as an example here's the cova
positivity rate testing and so we can
see if the positivity rate of code is
going up or down or what's going on with
it on a daily basis and so that helps us
understand you know is there a variant
that's coming that's going to need us to
to spin up operations as an example are
we going to need to be making more tests
to support the field how is it
performing do we have one of our targets
dropping out you know an scene target or
an engine target to you know that that
may be indicative of a new variant that
we have to respond to quickly having
that data in real time is really
powerful this also helps us understand
the inventories if folks are starting to
use more tests we want to be ready to to
also give them more tests so that no one
runs out
availability and supply chain has been a
huge issue for the last two years
throughout the tobin pandemic and any
edge you can have on predicting what's
going on allows us to keep stable supply
for our customers and allowed us to
never go on back order on our tests once
throughout the last 18 months or so that
we've had this on the market and that's
been voltage value for us but also
really the important thing is supporting
customers and ultimately they're
supporting patients and running these
tests that enable them to keep a
consistent uh standard of care in the
communities that they serve
in addition to that you know we have
work on uh going forward trying to
understand what kind of epidemiological
insights if someone's viewing this talk
and is interested please reach out to me
uh afterwards because we're trying to
pursue you know there's data that says
looks at for example uh sudden increases
in viral load in uh certain populations
can be indicative of a new strain right
coming up and that may give you a heads
up or an advanced notice that
something's happening before all of a
sudden 99 of the population
is
infected with a variant like the delta
variant as an example and so trying to
extract data on this aggregated data of
millions of samples is something that
we're looking to do i'm definitely
interested in talking if someone is is
interested in pursuing that as well
and then finally software support and
monitoring we want to ensure that you
know our customer experience is as good
as it possibly can be and so we want to
ensure that the the uptime is 100 that
people can use the test whenever they
want and that we're able to serve them
with tests as soon as they possibly need
the benefit here is that we can do this
all over the cloud and so it's easy to
ship someone a kit zoom them to do the
training they can upload the data and do
running with their tests the next day
finally as we start to think about the
assay now that we've designed the assay
we've engineered the asset we've
developed cloud tools that can help us
understand what's going on with the
assay we want to be able to use that and
leverage that to improve our our
products as you look at maybe a reason
that you know an assay wouldn't perform
as well as you as you would hope there's
so many different sources of noise
whether it's you know common cause noise
you know typically this is generally
normally distributed commonly
characterizable phenomena this is common
cause variation right maybe plate plate
reagents or reagents lots of lot
variation uh instrument variation
clinical sample variation in the case of
our uh eua assay as an example or what
we call non-gaussian variability this is
something that might be non-normally
distributed variation so this is a good
example of that that i already mentioned
is a stranger we might be concerned
there might be a strain variant popping
up or maybe sequence interaction or
something that's under the lod or
interfering substances or something like
that so because of this there's so many
different sources of variability it's
impossible although you know the the
process for getting one of these on the
market is quite rigorous it's impossible
to have everything fully understood new
variants can come out over time
that's really where the power starts to
to really uh
exercise itself here's an example of 30
over 30 000 samples of a cova test over
six week period fairly early on in the
pandemic
the
ability for us to monitor uh first of
all put 30 000 pcr curves on top of each
other in one plot uh helps us understand
you know how well the assay is
performing as well as the lot to lot
variability this was done you know early
on as we started to produce and starting
to ramp up this was over three lots of
raw material that we got from our
suppliers and we're shipping out and in
enabling and understanding that endpoint
intensity that the
variance between lots was very very
tight and
showed no significant differences was
really powerful as we get these new
products to market and you know we're
all ramping up at the same time trying
to serve
you know this uh in in this case the the
covid uh crisis people to understand
that the performance was good over time
and helping to make sure that that is
true and across manufacturing and supply
chain issues and things like that has
been really valuable for us over the
long haul
so in summary you know there's uh many
data science tools and methods that they
enable increase accuracy and robustness
from the upfront
product design and that can open new
areas in development you know this is
what enables our new technology and new
market areas that we can address with
gpcr that you can't and it enables uh
you know folks in the you know cell
image analysis to open up new market
areas as well so whatever you might be
doing with your company there's a lot of
valuable tools there that can help you
real-time
monitoring operational insight allows us
to keep our customers fed with tests so
that no one rent out and anybody who
needs a test can get it
allows us to also improve the product
and market or monitoring
and then finally really investing in
developing these data science tool sets
up front and your organization leads to
these huge benefits down through product
development and operational execution
all the way down as you as you go and
then once you're on the market that
starts to keep snowballing to get higher
and higher benefits as well as you start
to learn more about your products as you
learn more about the how to
stabilize them how to increase the
robustness and then ultimately launch
better products with more density of
targets in our case
down the road as you know
all right well thank you so much please
feel free to reach out to me if you have
any questions after you've viewed the
talk and thanks for joining me today